what are we making today i'm already
seeing uniqueness in the shapes we are
making my mozzarella stick salad so
they're basically miniature mozzarella
sticks that go on a bed of vegetables so
it's the perfect version of balance this
is my ideal weeknight meal and it's very
easy the hardest part is making the
actual mozzarella sticks so we have our
little cubes of mozzarella here molly
and you just take them through a
standard breading process so dip them in
the flour first get them nice and coated
you can do a few at a time
now transfer them to the egg this is
just beaten egg with a couple of
splashes of water
and then oh we've got to mix up our
bread crumb mixture this is a really
tasty bread crumb mixture there's both
panko and plain bread crumbs so you get
those two textures and then there's some
parmesan cheese and garlic and onion and
some italian seasoning it's a really
crunchy coating i also want to point out
this most beautiful spatula that i'm
using is molly's design made with
william sonoma to raise money for no kid
hungry these aren't william sonoma thank
you
very important thank you yes for each of
these salt
william sonoma no kid hungry donate
meals to kids in need okay so now once
we mix up our breading we'll take our
little cheese cubes
and dunk them into the breading
so you can actually bread these like up
to a day in advance really yeah
okay so now once we actually get these
breaded yeah oh i'm making a huge mess
here um we're gonna bread them again
okay to get an extra thick coat so dump
it back into reverse it so it goes back
into the egg and then again into the
bread crumbs and that way they stay
hotter longer they stay meltier and then
you just have more to control
but okay so we have some that are
breaded here should we get frying yes
okay let's fry okay so we've got our hot
oil here this is
a layer of oil in a pan you know how
when you have to give medicine to like a
pet you like a dog you you hide the
medicine in a lump of peanut butter yeah
this is how i think of this salad i hide
the vegetables underneath a betta cheese
wow look at how gorgeous and then you
get all of the food groups so yeah these
just go for a few they're already
getting golden oh yes let's mix up our
dressing okay perfect um okay of course
a mozzarella stick needs marinara
sausage this is just a dressing
version of marinara sauce i've taken my
favorite marinara added a little bit of
yogurt for creaminess some olive oil for
richness a little lemon juice to
brighten it up
so creamy dressing emulsified broccoli
wow you're fast okay so
for this salad this is these are the
veggies that we have some spinach
arugula olives which bring life to any
salad even the simplest salads love to
add olives
and then some cherry tomatoes chickpeas
for protein so do a little do a little
drizzle okay now we put the cheese on
okay
so this way this way the the cheese
cubes stay crisp on top oh my god these
look so incredible it's croutons when
you have fried cheese
molly look at this look how beautiful it
looks salad cheers
i love that you grabbed the fork i was
like
go
because i just really want it i just
want to eat cheese the child in my belly
wants to eat cheese
i
by the way what's your latest pregnancy
craving
this
[Music]
you